e la tutti ragazzi e barberi di questo
video sono fa vigenti ci siamo su the
visitor richards editors era scritto in
marrone merda quindi bisognava portare
un'intonazione di merda che ragazzi
scritto animato da james bridges barre
fuse pat quinn di un gioco della madonna
programmato da steve castro a posto
allora 26 steve castro music by sergio
muresan c'è michael jackson
comunque grazie per questa premessa di
di steve castro andiamo su click to play
perché allora io ho giocato il primo
visitors però lo ricordiate perchè non
ci ecco quello è il mio cane si chiama
ciuffo un bel canto ragazzi the visitor
ritorno la cinematica alla madonna link
alla prima inter ragazzi c'è scritto che
devo cliccare l'ambientazione per
assimilare le mie prede perché io sono
questo verme figo veramente i ragazzi
per chi si fosse perso the visitor e noi
non so con quale criterio 1 ma persona
possa perdersi in questo capolavoro
moderno che l'ente ragazzino sarei
questa questa cosa bella che sembra una
sottospecie di penne flaccido con due
orecchie il mio obiettivo e assimilare
le prede per i 20 ragazzi vi faccio un
esempio questo in teoria è un tasto e
dovrei riuscire a ucciderlo solo che c'è
ad assimilarlo proprio tipo majin bu
forse non ci sono riuscito però non
primo tentativo fallito ragazzi devono
uscire hard a farlo ma posso ovviamente
devo trovare nelle delle degli
escamotage madonna che non si esce
cioè abbastanza strana devo uccidere sto
procioni in qualche modo allora tolto la
luce prima cosa devo devo cosa devo fare
non lo so ci sono delle cose da fare
problema è che che cazzo perfetto
attaccato la presa della corrente al
tagliaerba attivato no cazzo sarà dato
cruciale ma no ma mi serviva è tornato
ma mi prendete per il culo dando alla
guardati con che classe torna indietro
fantastico
no scherzavo schiacciano sei un proto
procione di merda come si fa a farsa
parte impossibile che cos'ha fatto
capire che forse ho capito devo aprire
questa roba è quello modonna trojan si è
fatta tanto un bastone danno perché il
bie a che serve il bidone in realtà
adesso sono in fila nel deretano sto
coso non solo infine perfetto almeno
quello poteva andar per no no no a don
matteo schiaffi cosa devo fare adesso è
caduto il bidone è lei il senso adesso
che ti mangi sta roba posto e entrarti
nello stomaco
no no dei [ __ ] si accendono di
nuovo ipad 2 nello spazzato perfetto
così adesso mi mangia ok ce l'ho fatta
mezz'ora mezz'ora per stronzo è andato
sono diventato bellissimo ho bisogno di
una manicure abbastanza pesante però è
sempre qualcosa ragazzi è sempre
qualcosa sempre sexy ed importante quel
cos'è una puzzola bello beh ragni oppure
cosa deve assimilare per un giornale
giornale il giornale che prende la
puzzola il barattolo della puzza il la
birra della puzza dalla puzza della
birra cosa sta succedendo se no fare la
classe prima cosa prima di diventare
scemo fatemi capire la cosa bella ha
visto gioco ragazzi che diventa sempre
più strano ogni volta che assegnino
qualcuno li diverso è fantastico ok
perfetto le il legno l'omesso adesso il
barattolino perfetto il giornale
perfetto la birra birra possiamo mettere
e va beh devo accendere il fuoco in
qualche modo credo non lo so ho trovato
l'accendino giusto per ma che fa che che
muove ste cose poi in teoria sarà in lui
ok la puzzola è scappata perfetto chi
cazzo simile al bar il barattolino dove
vai e ti vai a bruciare non alla b le
famosissime puzzole alcolizzate ovvio
c'è il vetro posso entrare dal vetro a
caso ma è visto non lo sapevo non avevi
mai visto il vetro così a cazzo ma entro
proprio hanno un po a posto sbircia avrò
visto donne nude probabilmente va bene
che possono fare devo andare sulla birra
a nel barattolo scommettono dove cazzo
vado nell'oscurità
nell'ombra che sta succedendo andava
bene che schifo
ma cosa madonna scoraggiati fa grazie
veramente ma che cazzo viaggiato che
scoraggia gli faccio a vail fagioli gius
mangiato fagioli mi sembra ovvio sta
cosa al ragno diamogli al ragno che
scoraggia pure ragno la ragnatela il
regno sarà che sta succedendo è tutto un
trash è sceso un ragno perfetta massimi
la restò schifo cioè io ragazzi a me fa
veramente vomitare questa che tanto non
so se guardare o meno cioè il milan
attimo non è che mi trasformo in una
specie di ragni o cose così mi farebbe
molto più schifo pensavo peggio pensami
spuntasse la di paula 18 braccia adesso
posso piantarli una scuola pregio della
sua credo questo quello che mi ritrovo
spero lo sapeva ci avrei scommesso la
vita cioè prima lo catturato di bruto
fulvio che schifo no vabbè è la madonna
un petardo cos'è sta roba bello sono
pronto per una sfilata di moda credo
vado entrò nel fine possa entrare
finestrino adesso che sono così figo
perfetto
siamo entrati possiamo entrare che fanno
o squadrato dentro tipo mi ha aperto il
finestrino e geniale buongiorno mie
belle vittime amico mio sguardo serio
che ci ai temi infatti capire un anno
che questo beve fuma è già un cane che
figo della madonna alla prima cosa lo
scorpione prossimo piano mangiamo subito
bisogni e cresciuto un terzo bene
andiamo sul chiese by allora fatemi
capire
devo assimilare e cana e credo ma
ragazzi vi faccio una domanda ma se mi
assimilò sto tizio di vento per ato 5 la
qualità di stati babe fatemi entrare e
fare qualcosa in questa baia queste sì
cosa succede portesi lo sportello allo
sportello
la madonna che genio grazie ok l'ha
portato fuori perfetto ci affacciamo
ragazzi già facciamo ma deve uscire di
nuovo scendevo assimilare prima al cane
tipo entrali da qua oh mio dio che cazzo
cagato no vabbè ma sei serio problema
allora possa assimilare qualsiasi cosa
così mi sono diventa madonna un
coccodrillo mijas assimila un
coccodrillo che cazzo diventavo godzilla
ebbene ragazzino diventato leggermente
più dentato cegliolo partito gran verme
che cazzo sono diventato adesso fammi
capire un attimo se io tv alla madonna o
ninja nostri ragazzi vorrei che anche
[ __ ] la sua faccia quando me lo lancia
c'è proprio tranquillo
a caso va beh non è che prende la mira
proprio lui a caso così cioè ragazzi ma
manco lazio aspetta manco di sto cazzo
come che facciamo
gli devo rubare le sigarette ecco io in
qualche modo lo sapevo che le sigarette
c'entravano qualcosa possa accenderle
posso incendiargli l'alcol possa
incendiare qualcosa di più il fornello
fornello a sirone sciocco l'alcol a da
posso dargli fuoco la cala galan dalla
camicia lo so lo so lo so ho capito no
cala merda ma se io entro cos'è che
cazzo estero a scazzo sì sì ce l'ho
fatta un buco da lì fuoco direttamente
alla camicia facciamo prima che sguardo
triste che ciò
[Musica]
mi dispiace non vuole giuro che non
volevo che è ascolta zio io vengo
adeguati consolati con soliti vengono
sotto il tavolo ti entro dal culo posso
entrare che schifo di cosa è appena
successo
chi è quella amico mio ma c'è la donna
in camera che bella belen mi fai ti può
assimilare qualcosa di te oppure vado
via comunque devo ammettere che la
pelata era molto molto sexy famiglie in
camera visto che c'è la moglie stranota
credo che si è messo a sparare dalla
camera come cazzo facciamo nostro
fuggire dalla finestra
al rientro la lav ma qual è il senso di
o mio dio come faccio della birra con la
via d'acqua birra perfetto vai così vai
così assimila tutto assimilabile capito
se miles assimilo questa diventa un
mcdonald's credo alla peggio delle
possibilità allora devo decidere che
cosa utilizzare dei miei nuovi poteri io
utilizzerei eiaculazione precoce poi
eiaculazione dal culo anche se esco la
madonna cosa è successo ai cominciato
cismar garzia dopodichè andrei di punta
di scoppiare mamma sei veramente più
sexy di quanto a 90 proprio sta
diventando un kamasutra ragazzi è così
che si scopa tra insetti
adesso andiamo di pareggio tette proprio
no non ho sbagliato
ok e come ultimo ragazzi la limonata
perfetta proprio di lingua ci andiamo
eccolo qui perfetto io entro nel cuore
le persone super sayan di quarto livello
la prossima volta credo ragazzi abbiamo
finito casa cosa cazzo appena giocato
seriamente figo complimenti a steve
castro per aver c'è anche la pagina di
steve castro e lui incastro ragazzi
incredibile si incastra steve steve
steri ti metto come sfondo del desktop
si sfondo del desktop ragazzi ho messo
steve come sfondo del desktop
ricorda ragazzi conclusi il video anche
se non c'è per caso un altro perché
visitor giusto per prepararmi
psicologicamente
vi ringrazio tutti anche ringrazio
soprattutto anche steve per questo gioco
meraviglioso senza semi tra piaciuto al
trattamento mi piace anche a progetti
facebook e come ogni video trattando
estizione se pensate tutti quanti che
steve sia una persona [ __ ] lasciate un
altro mi piace perché due is meglio che
one belle ragazze